[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales à nous sommes le
lundi 7 février au sommaire aujourd'hui
elle pourrait voir le jour à l'horizon
2027 pour l'heure la maison d'arrêt de
magnanville t polémique ce week end une
centaine de riverains et des lustres
sont rassemblés pour manifester contre
le projet leur inquiétude dans ce
journal
la 5g en phase de test au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
objectif proposer une expérience
d'immersion totale lors d'événements
sportifs un projet développé en
partenariat avec nokia à l'approché des
jeux olympiques
et puis le palmashow était dans les
yvelines ce week-end pour présenter les
vedettes en avant première un film sur
le besoin de reconnaissance il sortira
le 9 février au cinéma nous avons
rencontré david marsais et grégoire
ludig
[Musique]
et la mobilisation se poursuit dans la
commune de magnanville contre le projet
de prison dimanche 6 février il était un
peu moins d'une centaine à se rassembler
le terrain est mal choisi selon les
habitants et les élus leur inquiétude
recueillis par nickel et demi d'euros et
mathilde de francs coup devant le lycée
léopold sédar et simplement d'une
centaine à avoir bravé la pluie et le
vent le sujet leur tient à coeur ils ne
veulent pas l'implantation d'une prison
à magnanville l'association tous
mobilisés contre la prison a publié un
manifeste de 24 pages afin de démontrer
que le terrain est mal choisi déjà
première premiers éléments il ya nappes
phréatiques sur le terrain il n'a
phréatiques et des des sources vagabonde
qui alimente j'irai l'eau l'eau potable
du mantois
ça veut dire que si on ramène 1200
personnes sur le terrain c'est à dire
700 700 prisonniers plus 500 500
travailleurs en risque de polluer le
terrain est pollué la nappe phréatique
autre point d'inquiétude le projet sera
construit sur une zone inondable avec la
bétonisation en cas de fortes pluies
l'association craint que le phénomène ne
s'aggrave mais ce qu appréhende
également les magnanville loi c'est le
flux de véhicules que la prison va
engendrer pour cette commune de 6000
habitants ans se pose de grosses
questions sur les mobilités puisque on
nous annonce un centre pénitentiaire de
près de 700 places avec à peu près
autant d'employés ça veut dire tous les
jours des salariés qui viennent sur leur
lieu de travail qui en repartent et qui
vont traverser notre commune qui est
déjà un peu particulière puisque on a
une départementale qui coupent notre
village en deux et qui passe non loin de
l'école d'un collège donc on s'interroge
sur leflux que ça peut représenter et la
sécurité de nos habitants et de nos
enfants pour le moment l'heure est au
dialogue et à la concertation les
habitants et les membres de
l'association ont de l'espoir nous quand
on a appris ça à fin septembre début
octobre tout le monde était inquiet bon
c'est vrai que maintenant on a rencontré
des politiques on avance on s'aperçoit
qu'ils aient un dialogue constructif
avec au démarrage ce n'était pas facile
la porte était fermée aujourd'hui les
portes s'ouvrent la future prison devra
contenir 700 places et voir le jour à
l'horizon 2027
vous l'aurez compris la construction
d'une prison à magnanville fait débat
nous avons interrogé michel vial et sur
le sujet les propos du député de la 8e
circonscription des yvelines recueillis
par mathilde de franco
[Musique]
si favorable à la construction de vingt
mille places de prison en france parce
que ça répond aux besoins
aux besoins qui sont les nôtres on est
sous dimensionné par rapport à ceux
trouvés dans d'autres pays par rapport à
la population carcérale actuelle et
celles qui ne réalisent pas c'est peine
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de place donc
pour toutes ces raisons je suis
favorable à la construction de places de
prison mais ça veut pas dire parce qu'on
est favorable qu'il faut les construire
n'importe où et n'importe comment
[Musique]
je pense que
on aurait pu et je pense qu'on devrait
observer ce qu'il ne peut y avoir on va
dire dans le grand bassin du mantois
dans ce tournoi exception là pour voir
s'il n'y a pas d'autres localisations
qui serait plus pertinente je pense que
la localisation en la matière nécessite
qu'il y ait du travail collective de la
concertation avant que de décider
brutalement c'est dans un lieu et pas
dans un autre
[Musique]
je sais que les services les services de
l'état ont des contacts avec les
associations et notamment l'association
tmc paix qui s'est très fortement
mobilisés et très rapidement mobilisés
sur ce sujet et je le comprends et je
sais qu'il ya des échanges j'espère que
ces échanges comment dire non seulement
seront nourries mais qui seront
constructifs
[Musique]
prévention de la délinquance et
éducation à la citoyenneté des
thématiques abordées ce lundi matin dans
le cadre d'une visite ministérielle à
trappes nadia ministre chargé de la
ville et marlène schiappa ministre
chargé de la citoyenneté se sont rendus
sur la commune yvelinoise au programme
rencontre avec les élèves de l'école
jean baptiste clément mais aussi avec
des policiers et des médiateurs de
bataillon de prévention ces derniers ont
pour mission de reconnecter les jeunes
de quartiers en difficulté à la société
ils sont dix professionnels à avoir été
déployés sur la ville de trappes et puis
également dans l'actualité le centre de
vaccination de saint quentin en yvelines
fermera ses portes le 25 février
prochain une mesure prise par
l'agglomération face à la baisse de la
fréquentation est si le centre a pu
accueillir jusqu'à 4000 personnes par
jour au maximum aujourd'hui moins de 500
personnes viennent par jour se faire
vacciner un chiffre qui ne nécessitent
donc plus la mobilisation du vélodrome
nationale qui peut accueillir jusqu'à
cinq à dix mille personnes le but passer
la main aux professionnels de santé du
territoire les médecins les infirmiers
ou encore les pharmaciens la machine
pourra être relancé en cas de besoin au
total 400 milles injections ont été
réalisés sur place
[Musique]
et on parlait justement du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines il
pourrait être sous le feu des
projecteurs aux jeux olympiques 2024 la
raison le déploiement de la 5g pour
l'heure en expérimentation jusqu'en 2023
le déploiement pourrait permettre une
immersion totale lors d'événements
sportifs et on parle justement de ce
projet avec vous thierry evanno bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur des projets
collaboratifs chez nokia france nokia
qui d'ailleurs pilote ce projet avec
d'autres partenaires pour entrer déjà
dans le vif du sujet l'objectif c'est
donc de courir autrement les événements
sportifs enrichir l'expérience des
spectateurs en quoi la singette
améliorer l'immersion est ce que vous
avez des exemples à nous donner
oui bien sûr donc le projet en
partenariat avec l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines a démarré ans
en 2019 quand ils ont obtenu pour
l'agglomération obtenu une fréquence
expérimental justement pour trouver
quels sont les nouveaux usages et
nouveaux services
que la 5g peut apporter et en
particulier ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'avoir des très hauts débits inat ans
préfète qui permet par exemple de chimay
en 5 g il y incruster des informations
en temps réel de type réalité augmentée
qui pourrait par exemple dans le cadre
d'un événement sur le vélodrome
d'apporter des informations
complémentaires
sur les sportifs voir
expliquer les règles
qui serait inséré dans la vidéo est dans
le le le la vidéo soit sur grand écran
au niveau du jérôme ou carrément sur une
application sur le smartphone par
exemple l idée cessé d'en faire un peu d
des stades en tout cas des lieux
connectés est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
aussi par exemple d interaction avec les
spectateurs
tout à fait donc c'est effectivement
vous l'avez dit c'est que le stade
devienne connecter un pour les propres
besoins du stade les propres besoins de
la compétition des juges des arbitres
des sportifs mais les spectateurs
puissent aussi avoir cette information
commentaires voire une certaine
interactivité l'ordre avec la
compétition en tant que tel mais on peut
l'imaginer des animations
ludiques et sportifs de sportif dans
lequel effectivement ou fait vivre un
moment donné à certains spectateurs ou
acteurs spectateurs
la manière dont l'événement et mises en
oeuvre ont fait vivre le spectacle et
voire même pourrait se retrouver
immergée sur la piste de manière de
manière
tout à fait
volontaire parce que hein il faut quand
même il faut quand même avoir les accès
menant données pour un point du mobile
se retrouvé immergé dans la compétition
et pourrait se retrouver finalement à
faire la compétition avec les vrais
sportifs et voire peut-être
les performances qui pourraient l'avoir
qui serait peut-être un peu difficile à
battre avec les paris sportifs donc
vraiment vraiment se retrouvé immergé
dans un événement avec des avatars par
exemple qui pourrait vous aimez tout ça
on en rêve et c'est pour ça qu'on essaye
de l'expérimenté de comprendre de quelle
manière on peut avoir ces nouveaux
usages réels
pourquoi selon vous on à ce besoin
d'immersion aujourd'hui d'avoir une
expérience plus large
on a remarqué une chose par exemple dans
les sports et c'est ce que nous disent
beaucoup de fédérations et aussi les
propriétaires de ce stade les exposants
de stade et de mieux faire comprendre en
fait un événement sportif déjà il ya les
fans absolus qui veulent un peu mieux de
comprendre les performances d'un joueur
si fish pas sportif quand même temps
c'est une manière de faire mieux
comprendre en fait un sport avec ses
règles et la meilleure façon peut être
de mieux le comprendre c'est d'être
immergé abandonné dans l'événement
de façon se rendre compte effectivement
de telle ou telle règle de telles
difficultés donc c'est une manière de
vivre l'événement sportif en fait de
manière différente on le vit aujourd'hui
en étant dans un stade pour lui dit
pleinement mais on pourrait le livre
encore différemment si on appelle
souvent le spectacle enrichi ou
l'événement enrichi de façon à mieux
comprendre mieux ressentir peut-être
aussi l'événement
en étant immergée abandonné dans dans la
compétition ou dans une animation
sportive et donc là on est encore dans
l'expérimentation on le disait quelles
sont les étapes clés ou en tout cas
quelles sont les prochaines grandes
étapes finalement de cette
expérimentation
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs étapes
effectivement on a depuis 2010 9
réfléchi avec les différents partenaires
de la fédération française de cyclisme
avec france télévisions qualcomm xds
emocion qui est sûre territoire de
coignières sur quels sont les usages
auxquels le vélodrome une fédération
sportive comme la fédération française
de cyclisme peut imaginer les nouveaux
usages donc on a listé différents usages
mais en fait on a 2 2 chambres
d'exploration c1 en profiter dans le
cadre des championnats du monde
le pis d'apporter une solution 5g pour
couvrir les besoins opérationnels
de l'événement avec un réseau entre
guillemets qui se développent et en
parallèle de tester donc entre
aujourd'hui et le mois d'octobre
ces premiers usages pour voir de quelle
manière soit de manière
un peu confidentiel parce qu'il ya
encore des tests à faire ou de manière
un peu plus large on peut les faire
expérimenter au coach aux sportifs aux
spectateurs de façon à en octobre déjà
avoir une première idée de ce qui paraît
viable intéressant
tu l'auras fameux effet whaou est
économiquement viable aussi et ainsi
continuer les expérimentations tout le
monde là dès 2020 2 tout le monde
l'analyse 2009 propres pour montrer que
la 5g peut apporter nouvelles façons
fait de vivre un événement aux
prochaines étapes là vraiment c'est pour
les championnats du monde
qualifiés je dirais certains usages
nouveaux pour les montrer et démontrer
donc ça c'est la prochaine étape donc
les les championnats et ensuite
peut-être les jeux olympiques du coup on
l'espère en tout cas c'est un peu
l'objectif merci beaucoup thierry evans
ou d'avoir été avec nous et je le
rappelle vous êtes le directeur des
projets collaboratifs chez nokia france
et justement elle participe aussi au
consortium 5g au tour de nokia xd motion
teste ses innovations en termes de
retransmission en télévision elle est
basée à coignières et la société de
production audiovisuelle utilise la
remote production c'est-à-dire piloter
des programmes à distance et aussi à des
nouveaux outils pour enrichir
l'expérience du spectateur les
explications de nicolas dand et
démultiplier les possibilités pour la
retransmission d'événements sportifs
voilà une application du projet
expérimental de la 5g au vélodrome
nationale des apparitions d'information
en réalité augmentée durant une
rencontre sportive ou encore
l'utilisation de la rue mode production
une évolution importante pour xd motion
on à l'utilisation maintenant de la 5g
pour pouvoir piloter à distance nos
systèmes nous ça c'est la grosse
évolution qui est en préparation on
reviendra dessus pour les jo de paris
2024 là ce que vous voyez c'est
à grande vitesse de déplacement du ce
qu'on appelle le hic selon l'un des
câbles calmes sur lequel nous avons
rajouté l'arrêté augmente et donc je
vous expliquais les tendances du marché
et de son évolution donc la remote
production et la réalité augmentée dont
tous les graphismes virtuel qui vient
d'être ajouté c'est je dirais les
prémices de ce qui va être utilisé par
la suite sur paris de 1024 x démotion
c'est une société de production
audiovisuelle
implantée à coignières elle fait partie
du consortium 5 g avec nokia qualcomm
technologies ou encore france
télévisions actuellement xd motion
travail sur les jeux olympiques d'hiver
apic un mois depuis maintenant les jeux
d'albertville donc ça remonte quand même
en 92
les effectivement les jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 aujourd'hui on les a
tous couverts on part on vient de finir
tokyo avec tous les drones qui ont été
qui ont été utilisés là bas sur place et
en chine on nous allons tourner tout les
sports extrêmes avec nos technologies
cavalcade pas le temps de souffler
puisque les premiers tests grandeur
nature au vélodrome nationales auront
lieu ce sera du tout au 16 octobre
durant les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
et côté sport à prison versailles
affrontera bergerac ce mercredi en quart
de finale de coupe de france la
rencontre s'annonce bouillante entre les
deux équipes de nationale 2 nous avons
suivi les versailles et sur cette
dernière semaine de préparation
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
grégory canale et bixente mais rien
senti steban dernière ligne droite pour
versailles avant son quart de finale de
coupe de france contre bergerac les
hommes de l'entraîneur youssef chibi
recevait ce samedi 5 février guingamp au
stade maubeuge l'occasion de préparer au
mieux le match de coupe c'est 17e
journée de nationale 2 débute bien pour
les joueurs locaux avec cette magnifique
frappe de la recrue hivernale johan brun
à la 17e minute de jeu 1-0 je tente ma
chance 1 après le gardien une femme
chicago aussi parce qu'elle est sur la
trajectoire existent rond un peu j'ai
pris ma chance ça m'a réussi mais la
machine se grippe guingamp égalise sur
cette action juste avant la pause
versets et réagi en seconde période le
club se procure des occasions et
touchera les montants mais ne marque
rapaces camp final 1 partout
malheureusement nous a manqué cette
qualité dans la finition chic avec un
poteau une barre des situations arrêté
par l'adversaire on n'a pas pour n'a pas
pu
je dirais traduire le bon comportement
des garçons au coup de sifflet final esi
rhinois se projeter déjà sur le match
contre bergerac
j'ai vraiment essayé de récupérer voilà
récupérer pour rejouer mercredi donc va
faire switcher dans nos têtes pour
passer aux quarts de finale et tout
faire pour essayer d'aller accrocher une
demi finale de coupe de france va
s'attacher à se reposer dès demain ou
pour ensuite ouvrir la parenthèse coupe
de france dès lundi il se préparer au
mieux pour cette rencontre mercredi on a
une semaine assez chargé avec trois
matches nous de faire en sorte de
revenir avec avec des points et du
sourire
ce lundi 7 février avant dernier
entraînement au stade de porchefontaine
avant le grand départ pour périgueux
sous le soleil dans une ambiance
détendue mais studieuse le staff est
revenu sur le match de ce week-end
contre guingamp avant de procéder un
décrassage du jour sont pas encore dans
le dans le stress aidant et dans la
préparation et la concentration du match
non c'est un peu oui c'est un peu une
une remise en jambes une un entraînement
un peu ludique pour récupérer du match
de samedi et puis je préparais dans la
bonne humeur des jeux
au match qui nous attend donc heureux
c'est une un petit intermède entre entre
deux matches l'occasion également pour
les joueurs de se mettre dans leur bulle
face à l'engouement médiatique d'un tel
événement cinq femmes ont
progressivement après moi je sais pas je
vais pas aller marcher dans toutes les
villes de me rendre compte de
l'engouement mais en tout cas au niveau
de mes proches je sens qu'il ya de
l'engouement qui qui montent donc quand
vous voyez sur les arrêts de bus et même
des affiches un peu par rapport au coût
au match de coupe de france donc ouais
ça monte progressivement et on va
essayer de faire perdurer cet engouement
les versailles et partiront ce mardi 8
février en train direction bordeaux il
prendra ensuite un bus pour aller à
périgueux un périple avec un objectif en
tête marquer encore un peu plus
l'histoire des yvelines jamais un club
du département n'avait atteint un quart
de finale de coupe de france
et on finit ce journal par du cinéma ce
mercredi 9 février sortira dans les
salles lé vedette un nouveau film du
palmashow réalisé par jonathan barré est
le duo humoristique illinois est venu en
avant première samedi 5 février à l'ugc
ciné cité de skywest de montigny le
bretonneux le reportage de ces diaga 200
go et grégory canale
vous chantez oui mais non ça j'arrête et
[Applaudissements]
chanter les gens qui sont seuls si
daniel quel pauvre à rodez bike
ok tout le monde en a un champion on
regarde les caméras sur lui
c'est avec humour forcément qu'ils font
leur retour sur grand écran le duo du
palmashow signe les vedettes daniel et
stéphane son collègue tout les oppose
mais ils vont participer ensemble à un
jeu télévisé objectif gagner de l'argent
et surtout briller en société un film
sur le besoin de reconnaissance et une
critique de notre temps
aujourd'hui on a en cours après les like
sur les réseaux sociaux après les gemmes
donc on fait un petit peu n'importe quoi
parfois on se rend ridicule on a envie
de passer à la télé dans été arrêtés les
télé crochets courts après cette
reconnaissance est ce qui nous plaît
dans ce film c'était de raconter
justement une histoire d'amitié entre
deux types complètement en marge très
seul qui cherchent à s'intégrer de cette
manière mais qu'ils le font de façon
complètement ridicule mais qui par
chance vont se trouver
passage obligé à l'ugc ciné cité de
skywest de montigny le bretonneux pour
l'avant première les deux amis
originaires de montfort l'amaury on
tourner une partie du film au bréviaire
parodier la télévision un défi à 6 en
plus pour le palmashow on essaie de
prendre des des émissions qui existe en
tout cas des mécanismes qui existent des
mécaniques des missions et après on y
glisse un peu notre humour différent un
peu à chaque fois
on essaye de garder une forme de
sincérité on peut être malgré tout pour
avoir de l'empathie pour n'importe quel
personnage j'ai pas si vous en avez
conscience mais vous avez un énorme
potentiel
six films plus jolie mention dresseur
six ans après leur dernier film la folle
histoire de max et leon les vedettes
sortira dans les salles obscures ce
mercredi 9 février et en attendant le
palmashow a publié deux nouveaux
sketches autour de la promotion du film
sur leur chaîne youtube toute façon faut
qu'on s'occupe de la promo des vedettes
là il faut qu'on la déchirure voiles
déchirées c'est quoi la première
interview
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
il sera accompagné de bixente mais rien
senti steban pour vos résultats du week
end très bonne soirée à tous sur télé 78
[Musique]